How do we construct a 30° angle To
construct an angle we need it's two arms
the initial arm and the terminal arm Let's
draw a ray b which will be an initial arm
Remember a ray originates from a
point and extends indefinitely in one direction
v  Need to construct a 30°
angle by creating a terminal arm we keep the
compass on point B and set it to
any convenient location with this we
draw an arc from now B crossing ray B at
point D do not change the  Compass
after you draw this arc with the left unchanged we
keep the compass at point D and draw an
arc now D creating point e and again do
not change the width of the compass we move the compass
to point e and draw an arc across the
previous  Arc Creating Point A We Draw A Ray
Starting From Point B Towards A
And Yes This Is A 30 Degree
Angle Remember Once We Make The First Tack With
The Compass We Make Two More Like This Without
Changing Its
[Music]
Width